obviously you're back in the suit yeah
suit's the same this time right or there
is it being changed or yes it's the same
yes okay as the last one there's no
changes again i asked for a zip and i
didn't get one
do you have a zip
uh yeah sort of
sort of it's not a conventional zip no
otherwise you'd see it but yeah we're
talking about the same zip right
there
i've said this publicly before because i
really think there should we should do
something about this i actually think
this should like all of us we need to
band together we need to tell somebody
because he he can like you know listen
it's one piece so there's a helmet and
there's all these things that go
underneath it and i always have this
fear that if he's like working really
hard or something's happening that if he
had to like throw up per se
what's how
how is he going to get it out
this is a genuine concern yes right so
it i honestly sometimes when i look at
him i'm like i get a little scared cause
i'm like what if you like i don't know i
don't know i don't know
it just stresses me out
but haven't you you've got better at the
suit though can't you you found a way
can you eat with the suit on some things
some things there's essentially they put
so the eyes pop out and there used to be
these fans i remember them bragging
about they added in these fans that you
could click and it would supposedly cool
me down they worked once
i have these hot batteries
but there's a there's a hole underneath
the eye socket where we used to be able
to feed a tube down oh no and i could
drink without taking the suit off
because it you know it takes a lot of
time and you've got a picture of this if
children have stayed up late to see
spiderman maybe they shouldn't see
spider-man drinking it's it's it's quite
unpleasant
[Music]
in ghostbusters there are lots of very
impressive special effects and visual
effects but you yourself using a camera
phone
you can create a visual effect
i can yes where it appears that people
are seeing something they're not that's
right okay can you demonstrate it
sure good
[Applause]
um can i just say you are all going to
be trying this
yeah this is uh
okay i can i'll try it on i knew that
okay okay okay what do i need to do just
sit there okay this should be fine
all right
i think we can
do you know what he's doing yes i do
you will in a miracle
it should be synced to uh yeah i think
it's sync now so here's the picture that
you just took
so
[Applause]
it does look like a bum
i know he much really confused
what what happened
oh yes do miriam there we go are you
doing it with your fingers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what is that
it does look like a bottom yes yes
i happen to have really sausage looking
fingers
that make a really nice tush and you can
frame you
you can frame it frame the camera so it
looks like you're just basically just i
just got to know how you discovered this
unique
there's an even more sophisticated
version
yeah okay
there's there's you can do i mean
well let's see if i can
i don't know if it's sophisticated is
the right word but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you've never lost your accent i mean
because you've been in america for a
while now yeah i've been there for a
while yeah for sure no i don't know it's
never
no
and is it true is it true that angelo
like picks you up on the way you think
he does but andrew sounds just like me
by the way like yeah so obviously the
whole time i've been there he's been
there and um he goes to school with
american kids and sounds like me um
so but yeah i kind of correct him a lot
as well obviously but that's how you say
it but yeah he does on
like you know the word like free is it
like the number three oh yeah he's like
it's not free it's like three like you
know he's got a little bit more well
spoken to me probably because of his
dad's but um yeah we've both still got
our accents and you live there and
obviously enjoy living there but there
must be things you miss oh my gosh yeah
i mean we weren't supposed to live there
this long or like you know before covid
we used to spend over half our time here
oh right okay then obviously you know i
got locked out the country with um
well if i came back here i wouldn't have
been able to get back there basically so
i was stuck there for most of kobe but
um
yeah i mean i miss like british i miss
british humor i mean
[Laughter]
yeah i miss the humor i miss my family i
miss you know a lot of them
like my condiments and you know i love
it i love a sauce like i love a sauce
marmite well i might not quite be very
but you know like salad cream and
branson's pickle and stuff like that you
know and um but i found a store there
that does it all oh hopefully i did she
said she said i mean
did it remind you uh jamie off yeah your
youth in belfast because didn't you have
a
you
would try to go to the cinema yeah a big
part of my youth going to cinema but
there's one
so this is bad like there's one time i
went to see um
me and about four my mates and i i i was
coming from a different direction so
arranged to meet the course and cinema
and the oral road and um we're going to
see this robert altman film called preda
porter because we heard there was nude
women in it
this is the word word got out there we
go
this is 1994 so we're all
well i was certainly pre-pubescent i
don't know about the other lads but i
was 12 and looked about six
um anyway so i turned up late and the
lads have already gone in
and this woman were working at the
cinema and i said
uh oh hi i'm here here is he pretty
porter excuse um and how old are you and
i went uh 12
and she was it's a 15 and i said
i'm
i'm 15.
you just told me you're 12. and i said
look my mates are already in there she
goes what age are they now
they're 12.
she's they she made me go and get all my
mates oh
you ruined it forever
so we went to see the river wild right
with meryl streep by the way great film
um
but not what the lads wanted to be
watching
um but actually it ended up being a bit
of a win because riverwild finished and
when we were walking back out we saw a
porter was still on and the final scene
is just topless girls walking down the
catwalk so we got in for that bit
you hosted the golden globes is it five
times yours
five times over ten years yeah okay yeah
because i don't know if you guys know
you probably don't know that the golden
globes have just sort of vanished they
didn't they didn't happen this year for
for loads because of you because yeah
i'm getting i'm getting the blame for it
i know i am yeah it was i really it
changed as well because the first time i
did it like 10 years ago the sort of
press particularly the industry press in
america was like how dare how was he
saying these awful things to the most
beautiful people you know and then by
the fifth time right they were going
good give it to him we're sick of
celebrities
so it was quite zeitgeister it sort of
hit a mark last time and that but i'm
really glad i did it but i think that's
enough okay you must were you in the
audience for any of ricky's school of
globes several times
it was a little bit i think it cuts to
you in one of them i think when you talk
about jeffrey epstein i don't know why
yeah to me
yeah but it's but it's a little bit like
the experience of being in the room with
you at the golden globes is a little bit
like the tail end of a family christmas
yes where you know it's drunk uncle yeah
yeah
do we show him where the bathroom is
do we just let him know i can feel that
and i can see the tension and then when
i do a joke about them they think oh
that was all right like leo gabriel was
sort of laughing thinking you could have
said a lot worse you know
i feel like at the end of a couple of
bond films we thought maybe it was going
to be your last one but this we know is
definitely the end bye-bye and i was i
was sort of going
at the end of spectre i was a bit down
on everything as um and i i thought that
was it and i thought i was just and
i'm really really happy that
i was given the opportunity to come back
and do this because i think we sort of
wrapped up a lot of the stories and and
and you know just a chance to come and
do one more was just
wonderful and does it feel like you know
is it sad or is it kind of a celebrity
is it kind of like wow i did an amazing
thing and i'm happy and are you kind of
thinking oh shame it's um it's a it's
everything i think and and i it's been
close to 16 years of my life and and
it's felt
it's been incredible to do these films
and not least of all to work with people
like this
to
bond movies don't get made very often
you know this it's rare air and to have
the opportunity to make these films has
been um one of the it's
the biggest thing in my professional
career clearly but one of the biggest
things in my life um and
it's very emotional it's it's um i i i'm
glad i'm sort of ending it on my own
terms which is really
i'm grateful to the producers for
allowing me to do that
um
but i shall miss it i mean i won't i
mean i'll probably be incredibly bitter
when the new person takes over
i'm happy for you but i'm sad for us
because genuinely you have been a
fantastic bond i mean so
that's the nominee ellen
no one was more surprised than me that
she said yes
can i tell you something can i tell you
what was happening in that obviously
that's the edited scene but i'll tell
you
we had a we had someone laurie the first
a.d was operating a fart machine just
off to the right and that isn't a real
bathroom that was a bedroom in the house
because the the bathroom wasn't small
enough wasn't big enough sorry so
we took a bedroom and we converted it so
it's a prop toilet prop sink
etcetera and um
so we had laurie uh operating a fart
machine just off to my right here so
that we could have the occasional subtle
little
break of wind from heleno while she's
holding me hostage in the toilet and i
was doing the scene
and then
he was getting so trigger-happy it was
ridiculous i was trying to do lines and
it was
it was bloody ridiculous so in the end i
had to stop acting i looked over at him
and he wasn't pressing the button
and i went
and i looked behind me
it was princess margaret going off
genuinely farting
and i only i'd only just got over the
shock that helena bonham cartridge said
yes to my thing and then she was farting
within feet of me
and she found it so funny she found her
own farting which was magnificent i
might say
she found her own farting so funny she
then worked herself
and had to leave the set and while she
was leaving the set she was shouting at
the top of her voice it's natural
[Applause]
talking of the voice how long
before you developed the voice or did
you find it pretty quickly uh i started
in the voice six months before we
started filming and then i stayed in it
while we were filming of course which
was really super fun for adam
[Music]
yeah i made him deal with that every
day
uh but you know i i'm still doing it
no but it actually for me i don't know
for what it's worth ridley shoots fast
and he's got four cameras going
once at any given time if not more so i
thought it was harder to go in and out
of character i thought it was actually
easier to stay in character on set so i
i wish not to sensationalize this thing
but i do wish to uh express gratitude to
my fellow actor that i was on stage with
every day
no okay
[Music]
you